The ground began to shake,
32 million people here in Tokyo
brace themselves for the worst.
8.9 magnitude, now we
know that's a big number.
It was the fifth largest
earthquake in history.
But the real damage comes
from the ferocious tsunami
that was unleashed.
In some areas,
the waves reached 40 meters in height-
Sweeping up everything in its path
including cars and ships
unable to withstand the strength
and the power of the surging water.
Japan is located
in the Pacific earthquake belt.
This means the country is struck
by some of the strongest earthquakes
and tsunamis in the world.
In the past decade,
about 30 tropical storms
have also hit the country each year.
These natural disasters kill
on average 100 to 200 people
per year and take a huge toll
on the country's economy.
But learning from painful experience,
Japan has built one of the world's best
natural disaster response systems,
which includes regular
disaster preparedness drills
and early warning alerts.
Japanese engineers and architects
have also pushed the boundaries
of technology and design
to create resilient,
disaster-proof buildings.
This is Tokyo Skytree.
At 634 meters, it's the
world's tallest tower.
Designed for broadcasting and observation,
the base of Skytree occupies a
relatively small plot of land
that isn't ideal for
such a tall structure.
Atsuo Konishi and his colleagues
designed a steel truss tower,
so instead of fighting against the wind,
it can simply pass through
the gaps between the trusses.
To stabilize the tower,
the team used a
traditional Japanese design
called Shinbashira that
dates back over 1000 years.
This is the flexible central
pillar of a Japanese pagoda,
which stabilizes the
tiered wooden structure
during an earthquake or typhoon.
In a similar way to a tree
trunk supporting its branches.
A Shinbashira has been found at the center
of the world's oldest wooden structure,
made from a tree felled in 594 AD.
For Skytree, the team
designed a 375-meter-tall
concrete core column
connected to the tower's steel outer frame
by a series of flexible oil dampers,
devices that control unwanted vibrations.
The swaying of the core
column and outer frame
in opposite directions
reduce the vibration
of the entire tower by up
to 50% during an earthquake
and 30% during strong winds.
The core column is set
on six seismic isolators made of rubber,
these absorb unwanted movement
and work together with the oil
dampers at various heights.
The top part of Skytree
is a broadcasting antenna.
To ensure high quality,
the antenna needs to stay
as stable as possible.
So two tuned mass damper
systems were installed
to reduce unwanted vibrations.
One is at an altitude of 625
meters and weighs 25 tons,
and the other is at an
altitude of 620 meters
and weighs 40 tons.
When the tower shakes,
these two dampers act
together as reverse pendulums,
reducing vibrations caused
by wind or an earthquake.
When Skytree was designed
in the late 2000s,
architects and engineers
flew weather balloons
to collect data on wind speeds
and build models which they
tested in a wind tunnel.
But for some building designs,
this expensive and time-consuming process
has been replaced by
faster and cheaper software
powered by artificial intelligence.
After a decade of research,
architectural engineering company Takenaka
has developed a typhoon
simulation software called Kazamidori.
For a 3 kilometer square urban area,
it usually takes three
months to build a model,
conduct a wind tunnel
test and get the results,
but with Takenaka's software,
the entire process can happen
in just two or three days
and its engineers are
trying to reduce that down
to half a day.
Japanese architects are also experimenting
with unconventional building
material for highrises.
Skyscrapers are usually
built from concrete or steel
because they're strong and cost-effective.
But building from wood is
more environmentally-friendly.
Compared with the production
of steel and concrete,
production of timber consumes less energy
and releases less carbon dioxide.
New trees can also be
planted to absorb emissions.
But building tall structures with wood
offers up its own engineering
and financial challenges.
That didn't stop Japanese
construction company Maeda
from trying though.
Maeda is going to
construct a 13-story wood
and steel hybrid office building
in Tokyo's Shibuya district.
To make the building earthquake-proof,
designers came up with a
hybrid lattice structure
that will support the walls
and create a more
user-friendly experience.
These designs and technologies
have helped high-rise buildings
to withstand typhoons and earthquakes.
And now many low-rise buildings in Japan
are starting to adopt them as well.
Some vulnerabilities still exist,
like older buildings constructed
before regulations were tightened in 1981.
With natural disasters becoming
more and more frequent,
these innovative designs and technologies
could be key to protecting
the economy and lives
both in Japan and around the world.